15 років тому Росія напала на Грузію
світ висловив просто глибоке
занепокоєння і продовжував купувати
російський газ Український президент
Ющенко був чи не єдиним хто тоді
закликав світ діяти активніше ввести
санкції проти російської федерації і він
говорив що Україна буде наступною
Сьогодні ми бачимо що не покаране зло
воно завжди повертається Росія має бути
покарана за всі свої злочини в Грузії в
Україні в будь-якій війні винні всі
росіяни які це підтримують які це
толерують які мріють про Відродження
радянської імперії і тому
відповідальність за війну і Грузії і в
Україні внесе і Путін і Медведєв і все
як Ванда і всі росіяни і вони мають за
це відповідати